nether realm have released a mortal
kombat x patch which aims to seek
gameplay just today after they release a
pc early patch to make the game well
work the game plan changes includes the
following all throws no longer connect
after counter hit Takeda's ronan
variation guessing you move that
retrieves drops blades and shin ox
imposta variation can now control the
location of a stolen Goro stomp patch
1.2 also includes a classic skin horse
of 0 as for the PC patch from the end of
last week and nether realms have fixed a
bunch of problems and also issued PC
players 10,000 digital Mortal Kombat
coins to say sorry for that whole game
not working on launch day thing nether
realm creative director ed boon said
that mortal kombat x has marked the
biggest launch in the franchise's
history you can check out the full list
of patch notes on gamespot let me know
if you've been playing Mortal Kombat X
and if so who's your character of choice
we'll keep you updated on all the latest
so stay tuned to gamespot